の振動を脳に入っちゃうと
たまにこの快感の物質が生まれるんです
いつでも生まれないんです
もしその快感を作ってくれる物質は
脳が勝手に作っているんだったら
一生楽しいでしょう 何もなくても
で このうつとかね そういう状態になる人々の場合は
脳の伝達物質が足らないとかね
それで薬でみんな明るくなるんだとかね
まあアメリカだったら結構今子供たちにもこのうつ的な子供たちやら
神経質な子供たちやら
この激しい子供たちにいつでもまあ薬ばっかり飲ませてるんです
脳の薬 それ飲んだら脳にこの欠けてる物質などが生まれてきて
いくらかは良くなるんだと
あとでどんな結果になるかわかりませんだけどね
まあ一応やってるんですね
そこである人は言いましたけどね
これ薬に頼らないで 自分でその脳でその物質作ったらどうですか
そういう方法を教えてあげますけど
あまりやりたくないんだと
まあどうとか まあ薬飲んでくださいと言ったんだけどね
で 物に頼ると快感消えちゃうんだから
心が自分で楽しみを味わうようになっちゃうと
ずっと幸福でいられるんです
このずっといられるっていうことは
ちょっとした言葉だけなんで
ずっとの何もないんだから
これ全部変化しますけど
その瞬間瞬間の変化が幸福の変化になるんです
それで仏教では違うこういうことを言うんです
人間は不幸を感じる時はまず計算する
これお医者さんと同じ仕事だから
すぐ不幸に合わなくちゃいけないんです
人間は不幸だ 悲しみだ
苦しみだ 嫌だと やりきれないんだとか
そういうふうな時あるでしょ
もうやりきれない もう全部投げ捨てたいんだと
もう逃げたいんだ もう嫌だと
なんで私は不幸やとか
そういうふうに思う時
いくらでもあるんですね
その時は喜悦感ではなくて
ものすごく不幸を感じているんです
暗くて暗くて そういう時もあるし
あんまりにももう落ち込んじゃって
何もやりたくないんだと
そういう時もあるし そこであまりにも自分のことを嫌で
大胆なことしちゃうと
車に乗ってものすごいスピードを出すとか
あるいはもうガブガブガブガブ酒飲んで飲んで
もうもう倒れると思うとこで酒飲んじゃうとか
あるいはもうパチンコに行っても
もうあれだけのお金全部賭けちゃって
もうもう家のものを売ってまでやるとかね
そういうこのもうあるいはもう誰かに向こう
誰かをぶん殴ると 子供たちやるでしょうに
誰かに暴力振るうとか
あの時のその人々がね
ものすごく不快感 不幸感を感じている時なんです
たまに道路でも外を歩く時でも
あの今十四歳の子供たちも危ないんだけどね
まあ子供だから可愛いと思わないで
ちょっと気をつけた方がいいんだけど
ちょっと事を間違ったらもうどうするかわからないんです
で その瞬間にその子は
例えば悪いことをする子はもう幸福で満たされているかというと違うでしょう
不幸でもうどん底なんですね
そこで人を殴ったり もう人を殺したりはするんです
私たちもいろんなことを失敗しちゃうと
誰かをぶん殴りたくなっちゃうんですね
でも体も弱いんだから
あんまり弱い相手見つからないんだから我慢しようと我慢しますけど
それでもストレス溜まっちゃうんですね
そういう不幸な時 我々にもあります
いつでも幸福わけじゃない
そこでその不幸な時は
幸福な時は脳がこの快感ですか
このいいホルモンを出してくれると
同じく不幸な時はものすごい悪いものを出すはずなんです
そこで体も心もそれに慣れちゃうんです
簡単に 心が一つの訓練するんですね
いわゆる まあまあ他の言葉で言いますが
我々は常に失敗を心配したり
嫌になったり 喧嘩したり
不幸を感じたりしていると
心はいつでも脳がいつでも悪い物質を出さなくちゃいけない
不快感の物質を作らなくちゃいけない
いつでも作らなくちゃいけないんだから
脳の中でこの食べるものから来るホルモンで
あ これたくさん売れるんだから作ろうと大量生産するんです
いつでもそうでしょう
もう法則っていうのは
店で種類のレパートリーと言うんですか
この食べ物を用意してあっても
来る来るお客さんが品しか注文しないと
他のっていうのはものすごく稀に注文するんだと言ったら
その店の人は買い物するとどういう風に買い物します？あの種類の品物を作れるようなものをずっとたくさん仕入れするんです
体も同じく で 悪い不快感の物質作っちゃえば
我々のホルモンがアミノ酸やらもう脳に入っちゃったら
脳があのこれ作らなくちゃ
これ結構売れるんだということで
結構必要になるんだと
だから専務この不快感のホルモンを作るように
ホルモンと言わないね
いろいろ脳 まあ脳内物質ですけどね
作れるようになるんです
そこは仏教でもちゃんと知っていて
悪いことを二度とするなと
いいことだったら強引にでも繰り返し繰り返ししろ
悪いことっていうのは
不快感を味わう行動 いいことっていうのは快感を味わう行動
それ繰り返し繰り返しやりなさいと
そうすると あなたの心が完璧に幸福に満たされますと
我々がいつでもあの 喜悦感を感じる
幸福を感じる物質を作るようになっちゃうと
脳の立場から考えちゃうと
この品物をいっぱい作らなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 何だかんだもいい方向へ変えちゃう
それは一般的 宗教的に喋るとこういうことなんですね
楽しい人は何でもいい方向へ変えちゃうでしょ
楽しい明るい人は不幸になっても明るいんではないか
例えば人が死んじゃって
葬式の時でもすごい明るい人が来ると
ゲラゲラ笑わなくてもなんとなく落ち着いて雰囲気がいいでしょうに
ですから その論理なんです
その人の脳が知らない
この不快感の物質を作ること
知らないんだから 不幸に出会ったのは不幸なんですけど
脳が快感の物質を作っちゃう
例えばお金がなくなったと
その人があーいやどうしようかって困っちゃったなとかね
っていうことじゃなく
あら お金がなくなったよと
それで笑うだけ  [笑い]誰かに取られたでしょうねとかね
で 自分に笑ったりとかね
やっぱり私は間抜けだからね
もう簡単に取られたでしょうねとかね
そう楽しく取っちゃう
本当はお金がなくなって普通だったら大変なのに
その人にとってはそれは楽しいこと出来事になっちゃう
そこでじゃあお金がなくなったと
じゃあどうしようかと
電車で帰れないと で そこら辺いろいろ工夫しなくちゃいけないでしょう
そこら辺も楽しくて そこで知ってる人に電話してとかね
友達から頼んでとかね
こういうことになったんだからね
ちょっとお金貸してくれと
それで貸してもらったと
その時やっぱり助かりましたと
やっぱり友達がいて いかにと
こうやっぱり素晴らしいんだと
それでうちに帰っても
例えば友達ではなくて
全く知らない人に助けてくれたんだと
お金なくなったこと分かって
大丈夫 これでうちに帰ってくださいと
で うちに帰っても 今日は自分の財布を盗られちゃって
満員電車で あれいいことを勉強しましたと
やっぱり世の中で素晴らしい人がいるんですねとか
そこら辺見るんです 世の中で泥棒ばっかり
今の日本では何ですかとかね
そんな暗い考え方ではなくて
今の日本ではもう安心して電車にも乗れないんだとか
そういうことじゃなくて
やっぱり世の中捨てたもんじゃないんだとか
よく親切な人がいるもんだねとかね
仏様みたいにその時よくも助けてくれたとか
そういう風に明るい方を見るようになります
ですから 心がこの幸福を作るプロセスに入っちゃったら
生き方はあまり関係ないんです
洪水になろうが乾季になろうが
心がもう知らないんです
不幸になること ケース感ばっかり作っちゃうんです
それこそが幸福なんです
お嫁さんの衣装を着ることは幸福じゃないんです
で なんで私はその合わない言葉を言ったんですかというと
そうするとおかしいではないかと思っちゃうでしょうね
乾季になろうが洪水になろうが
人は幸福やというと 世の中のことを無視することではないかと
世の中を良くしなくちゃいかないんではないかと
経済状態であろうが 健康状態であろうが
毎日良くせねばいかないんではないかと
私に言いたがってるでしょ
心の中で そんな雨が降ろうか
雪が降ろうか 私は幸せだっていうのは
なんかちょっと危ないんではないか
私はもっと大胆に言うんです
家が火事になろうが 自分の家族の人々は死のうか
究極的に幸福を味わってくださいと
二つかにでも悩むなと
その道だよと いいと それこそ大胆的に言うんです
そんな無神経でという反応するでしょうに
そんな鈍感で無神経の人間にはなりっこはないんだとか
それは鈍感でも無神経でもないんです
その言ってる人が本当はすでに鈍感で無神経で無知で
どう思ってるかというと
世の中変わると自分が幸福だと馬鹿みたいに思ってるんです
ということは お嫁さんの衣装を着たんだから幸福でしたと
バカなこと思ってるんです
綺麗なウェディングドレスを着ることができた
だから私は幸せでしたと
そうじゃないんです ウェディングドレス着たところで心が快感が生まれただけなんです
ウェディングドレス着たところで心そんなに幸福でしたならば
なんで高価なウェディングドレス 20着ぐらい買って家に置いておかないんですかね
80歳になっても着て
もう鏡で自分の姿を見て
なんで楽しまないんですかね
そうじゃないでしょう
だから世の中のせいじゃないんです
我々の幸福も不幸も 自分の心の方法なんですね
だから真の幸福っていうのは
豊かな時味わうものだけではなくて
貧乏な時も幸福なんです
人は豊かであろうが貧乏であろうが
幸福を本当に感じている
本当に楽しくてしょうがない状態にいるならば
それは幸福なんです 高級レストランでご飯食べても
屋台でラーメン食べても
ものすごく幸福を感じるならば
同じく平等に幸福を感じるならば
それは幸福なんです 屋台でラーメン食べて
なんで私は不幸だと ここら辺でこんな安いラーメンしか食えないんだとか思ったりする人は
もう究極に不幸なんです
何があろうとも心の幸福を変えないように作ら出さなければいけない
そこにいろいろ方法があります
言いかけてきたことなんですけど
また戻ります 話は 私たちはものすごく落ち込むとき
嫌になるとき 苦しみを感じるとき
人をぶん殴りたくなるとき
学校に爆弾でも仕掛けたくなる時とかね
子供たちがそうなったりするんです
爆弾持ってないんだから
ガラス窓ガラスぐらいを割って割りますけどね
その時はすごく不幸を感じているんですね
その時の心を見てみましょう
その時の心 その時の心は不幸なんです
もし子供がそのことをやったら
先生が子供先生がこう聞くべきですね
なんであんたガラス割ったんですかと
ではなくて 君 そのガラスを割った時の君の心わかってるんですか
その時どんな感じですかと
その時子供はゼーゼーしましたと言うかもしれませんよ
いえ このゼーゼーする前にどんな気持ちでしたか？すごい気持ち悪かったんですか？ガラス割る前に
楽しくてしょうがないから
だいたい子供はあまりわかりませんだからこちらからちょっと答え出さないと言ってくれませんだけどね
楽しくてしょうがなかったか
あるいは嫌で嫌でぶっ壊れしたい
もうぶん殴りたいほど嫌な気持ちでしたか
そうすると答えは明確です
ぶっ壊れたい 壊したいほど嫌な気持ちでした
それでその嫌な気持ちが危ないんです
この嫌な気持ちがあったんだから
君がこの窓ガラスを割ったし
みんなに悪い子やと思われちゃるはするんだけど
問題は窓ガラスは10枚割ったって大したことはないんだと
学校にも火つけたくても
それはもう大したこと
また作ればいいんだと
学校っていうのは 他にあるんだからねと言って
問題は君の気持ちだと
この心に現れたこの嫌な感情だと
今窓ガラスで割ったんだけど
その感情を引きずっていくと
人殺しまで行くかもしれませんし
ですから 何が何でも喜びなさいと
喜びを感じなさいと教えてあげなくちゃいけない
なぜかというと みんなすごい喜びを感じる時は悪いことしないんです
ですから 我々は小さい時からも頭に教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
この感激 喜びを感じること
それでちょっとまた危険なところがあります
皆様方 世の中で思っている喜びっていうのはとんでもない悪いんです
それは競争すること 人を倒すこと
金儲かること 自分をよくよく見えること
見せること いわゆる自己破壊することを幸福だとものすごい悪い
悪い間違っていることを教えているんです
成績はすごい素晴らしい成績出すこと
だから会社に入ったってもいい成績出そうとバカみたく頑張ってるんだ
それ自分も破壊して会社も壊す
倒す 倒すと そういう道じゃない
それをちょっと分かればいいんです
こういうことなんです
この嫌な時は 我々はものすごく怒り
心の中にあるんです 怒りがあって
希望があって 希望ができない
絶望感が生まれる それから怒りが出てくる
自分が戦おうとする でも相手は手強い
子供たちも同じなんです
もう最高な成績出そうとする
でも他のクラスの人々
みんなもっと上手で もうできないし
それで簡単に怒っちゃう
なぜ怒るかというと もう親からが先生からずっと言われてるんだから
戦え戦え それで怒りが出てくる
それで憎しみが出てくる
それで嫉妬が出てくる
それから恨みが出てくる
そこで心がそれに勉強しちゃうんです
それに慣れてしまっちゃう
何て言うんですか その癖付き
癖がついちゃうんです
それでその人は知っているのは嫉妬
怒り 憎しみ それでも人生終わりなんですね
そこで私たちはいこういうんですね
嫉妬はしてはいけない
憎しみは良くない 怒りは良くないんだ
競争は良くない 戦うな
相手と 誰と でも代わりに
慈しみの心 生命を平等である
みんな一緒やと そこで戦う相手がいないでしょうにね
それ分かったら で そういう気持ちを育てる
で 私たちおっしゃってる慈悲の瞑想なんかは
やっぱりまず自分が幸福で幸せでありますように
当たり前の話でしょうに
だから 私は幸福でありますように
その念じながら 自分の幸福を
何て言います イメージでもして
ほんのちょびっとでもいいんだから楽しめばいいんです
やっぱり幸福になればいいなと
幸福になったようなつもり
苦しみ 悩みなくなりますようにと思うと
本当に自分にあるいろんなくだらないでもし
まあくだらないかあるかわかりませんだけど
自分の本当の悩みやら苦しみやらそれやっぱり消えた方がいいなとか
なくなったらいかに楽しいかと
その幸福をイメージしてみるんです
自分の願うことは叶いますようにという時は
いろいろ自分も小さな小さなことにチャレンジしているんだから
そういうのはうまくいけばいいなとかね
できたらどれほど楽しいかと
その楽しみを味わってみる
我々の瞑想では悟りの光が現れますようにって言うんだけど
一般的には智慧が現れますようにと言うんですけど
自分に智慧が現れたら
もう何でもよく理解できていいのではない
そういうふうに自分のこと
自分の心で幸福感を味わってみようとする
そうすると自分のことを思うと
自分は一番可愛いんだから
頭の中ですごく楽しみが生まれてくるんです
心の中に 愛想憎いとか
ぶん殴りたいとか倒したいとか
そういう気持ちは出てこない
なんとなく自分の中から楽しくなっちゃう
それで一人の人が一人自分だけ楽しくてニコニコしていたっても
それほど力強くない それで自分の付き合ってる自分の関係ある人々のことを思う
同じく念じてみる 自分の家族やら親戚やら友達たちやら
だってこうでしょう 例えば
自分があるレストランで美味しいご飯食べたかった
一人で行くのは寂しい
楽しくない それで強引に友達に友達に頼む
一緒に行きましょう 友達は忙しいんです
そこであまりにもこっちはせつこいだから
友達はまあしょうがないと来ると
そこで友達はただ付き合ってるだけやと分かると
自分の楽しみも消えちゃうでしょうね
なんとなく申し訳ないと引っ張り出して
なるでしょ？大体 そこで強引に引っ張ったんだけど
その友達はなんというか
自分よりもその店の食べ物は食べたくて
その注文したものはもう大好物で
ものすごく喜んじゃったんだと
結局自分よりも相手がすごくも喜んでしまったと
そうすると自分の気持ちはどうですかね
それで申し訳なかったとか何でもないでしょうに
いいことをしたんだと
だから相手も喜んでくれると本当にすごい楽しいんです
今のお母さんたちでも一生懸命料理作ったりするんだけど
食べる人々はもうもうむちゃむちゃむちゃむちゃ食べて
ものすごく美味しがって
楽しく美味しく食べると
あれで あの料理作った苦労
全部何のことなく消えちゃうでしょうね
ああ よかった もし間違ってでも子供はあまり言わないんだけどね
まあ子供は好きな食べ物を作ったところで
子供がまあお母さんのこと大好きですよと
やっぱりお母さんのこと私は好きですねとご飯食べながら言うと
まあお母さんは分かってる
まあこいつはまあ作ったもの美味しいんだから言ってることでと分かってはいるんだけど
まあすごく幸福感じるんです
その瞬間に それは本当の幸福なんです
ですから 自分の周りの人々
自分の友達 親戚 家族 同僚の人々
みんな幸福であってほしい
幸せであってほしいという気持ちを自分でイメージをして
心に教えてあげる この喜悦感の物質を作る方法
それで究極的に一切の生命はみんな幸福になりたがっているんだから
すべての生命は幸福であってほしいと
そこまでイメージを膨らませちゃうんです
そうすると どれぐらい幸福を感じると思います？自分の一人の子供があまりにも美味しくて
食べて お母さんのこと大好きですよと言った途端
言った瞬間で味わう幸福と
すべての生命のことを幸福で感じる時に味わう幸福と比べますかね
比べられません 我々は分かってないだけなんです
本当は富士山ぐらいの財産に権利は持ってるんです
富士山ぐらいの金の塊が自分のものなんですが
自分で知らないんです
それで 砂 1粒ぐらいの金を持って
やっぱり私は金を持ってるんだから金持ちやとか喜んでるだけなんです
本当はあの その 1粒ぐらいの金を持って金持ちと言うんじゃなくて
このアホに富士山ぐらい巨大な金の塊があるんです
わかってないんです どこにあるかと
仏教はそれを言ってることなんです
我々はそんなちっぽけな小さな幸福も
それでもものすごく苦労しているものだから
たまに感じるだけで ですから
この慈悲の気持ち 一切の生命に我が子のように愛する心が生まれたら
その人の力っていうのは神と等しいんだそうです
すべてのものを自分 希望通りにいけるようになっちゃうんです
それはすごい力なんです
だからこの心っていうのは
この喜び感じると もうものすごい並のものじゃないんです
この昔いろいろ奇跡を起こしましたとかね
仏教では神通力いろいろやったとか
そういうのはこの心でそのエネルギーをすごく作ってあるんです
だから我々は全然もう何ももう髪の１本１本も動かすことできないんです
だから暗いエネルギーしかないんだから
ですからこの心に教えてあげます
暗いエネルギーを生まれてくると
すぐそれを止めてもらって
いつでもこの慈しみの気持ち
それはどんな宗教でも同じなんです
愛の教えだから 人を愛する
自分を愛する 家族を愛する
同僚を愛する 他人を愛する
すべての生命を愛する
生きとし生けるものを愛する
そこに戦いはありません
誰も敵じゃない 誰も同じなんです
平等なんです ですから
この愛の教えはどんな宗教にもあるのが
それもいい加減で教えているんですね
人間だけ愛しろと あるいは神を信じている人々は救われますから
他の人々は救われません
だから地獄行きだからもう愛してない
殺してもいいんだとか
それで戦いがまた生まれてくる
まあ宗教歴史的にそういうことはあったんだからね
今もないわけじゃないんです
自分の宗教を信じている人々だけ正当派で
他人がもう正当派ではなくて邪教だと
同じ宗教の中でも派閥あって
お互いに殺し合いやったり
喧嘩したりする プロテスタントとカトリック教がイギリスでね
やってるでしょう 同じジーザスを信じているのに
それで殺し合いになる
またもうヨーロッパ人だ
文化人だとかね また我々を偉そうなこと言いますけど
私にはまるっきりわからないんでね
あの気持ちが 同じ聖書だからね
同じ宗教だから 同じキリスト様だから
ただ名前だけ変わったことで
お祈りの仕方がちょっと変わっただけで
神はどっちでも聞いてるんだから
もし神はもう一人の宗教のことだけ聞いてるならば
神もバカもんだからそうじゃないし
で なんで喧嘩するでしょうかね
だからそちらに愛がないんですね
愛があるのは蟻一匹でもゴキブリ一匹でも
目に見える小さなダニ一匹たってもね
元気で頑張ってるんだと
ダニでも顕微鏡で見てください
可愛いもんでしょう 一所懸命
だから可愛いっていうのは
この私はこの一所懸命生きているこのあの姿なんですね
かわいくないかもしれませんだけどね
でも結構別に格好悪いわけでもないでしょ
よく見ると だからこの描いてみてください
その時すごく愛情が生まれるんです
この学校だったらやれますからね
あの顕微鏡で見ながら描いてみる
自分で 描いてみたら すごくなんとなく愛情が生まれてきます
そうすると そのいろいろ我々と同じく
いろんな感覚部品がついていて
いくらかないんだけど
で でもあるもので十分生きてるし
自分なりに 別にわざわざと人間と恨みあるわけないでしょ？ダニが
たまたま人間が悪くて
部屋の掃除を怠ると 人間の体にいきわるだけであって
悪いのは人間ですから
別にダニじゃなくて 部屋は綺麗だったらね
どんなにダニがね そいつするわけじゃないし
でも結構まあ元気に頑張ってるしね
我々の皮膚を乱ってもね
いろんな微生物は生きてるし
だからこれ見ると頑張ってるなとかわかっちゃうと
なんとなくどこかでなんか愛情ってもの生まれてくるんですね
それが慈しみなんです
敵だと思うのは慈しみじゃないんです
戦わなくちゃ 壊さなくちゃ
倒さなくちゃ それは怒りなんです
戦ったところで 倒したところで
相手に勝ったところで幸福ですよというのは真っ赤な嘘です
相手に勝って一度も幸福を感じることはないんです
世の中 相手に勝ったら勝った瞬間から不安でビクビクして生活しなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ現代医学はウイルスに勝ったんですか？微生物に
ウイルスに 細菌に 結局負けてるでしょう
勝てないんです 共存するしか方法ないんです
ウイルス 細菌 全部片っ端からやつけろうとすると
そのグループが死ぬんだけど
やっぱりこの存在の中で一つ消えるとreplacementという機能があるんだから
そこに他のものがその穴に入るんです
だってそうでしょ 人が借金だらけで建物を売っちゃったら
他の人が買うでしょうに
その法則 なんで忘れてるんでしょうか
我々はこの地球から消えると
他のグループがreplacement英語で言ったら何て言います？入れ替わる
入れ替わっちゃうんですね
だからあるウイルスを
ある細菌を殺しちゃうと
当然そのレベルの他のもので入れ替えるんです
それを科学者が忘れるんですね
宇宙の法則 生命の法則
それでその薬効かない新しいものが出てくる
それでまた殺してやるぞと新しい薬を作る
そうするとその細菌は死ぬ
それでまた新しいものが入れ替わる
それでまた殺してやるぞと
いつまでやるんですかね
それは 共存しちゃったらそれで終わりですから
だから競争ではなくて共存の生き方
それこそ素晴らしくて
統率 統越した生き方なんです
超越した生き方なんです
これ 気が弱くて 人間どもっていうのは自信がなくて
なんかなんかもうね 例えば私はよくこの鉄砲とか持ってるでしょ
アメリカとかの人々というのはものすごい気が弱いんですね
武器を作ったり 武器を作りながら自分を守るために巨大なシステムを作らなくちゃいけないでしょうし
あんなもうもう人間にもないんだと
見みするほどもないと思うんです
私は 私はどうせ勝手に思うことだから
別に皆様に関係ないんだけど
そう見えちゃうんです
弱い人やと 何もない状態ですごく元気なんです
私が言うのは 例えば私も坊主なんですけど
お守り一つも身につけてない人はすごくいいんだと
そうするとお守りでもあると
その分ちょっと弱いということなんですね
守りですから 弱みを守るんだから
ですから そういうこの人と戦おうと
いろんな戦う論理っていうのは弱い者の論理です
もっと激しく言うならば
間抜けな人間の論理です
戦わない あなた どうぞ自分で勝手に共存してくださいと
ということはすごい人の生き方なんです
それこそ幸福の生き方なんですね
ですから 共存の生き方ではなくて
間違った競争の生き方ではなくて
共存の生き方こそが幸福の道なんですね
ですから 我々はこの慈しみの心を育ててくださいと
全ての生命に対して 生きていきるものに対して
それすごい簡単 自分の心の中でこの脳細胞に教えてあげること
この充実感 幸福感 味わう方法
だから一番簡単なのは
私は幸せでありますようにと
私に私の仕事上手にできますようにと
と思ったりして 頭に教えてあげる
喜ぶこと 常にいつでも喜ぶこと
それを覚えて覚えておけば
我々はおにぎり食べようか
なんとか伊勢海老食べようか
脳細胞がおにぎり食べたんだからといって
この不幸の物質作りますと
なんて伊勢海老食べると幸福の物質作りますと
そういう風になってるんですね
今はないんです おにぎり食べようか
伊勢海老食べようか 脳がもう脳の工場で一つの工場はもうもう破産状態になりますから
不幸作る工場が破産状態になりますから
売れないでしょうに 瞑想しちゃうと不幸の物質売れないと工場は破産でしょうね
そうするとこちらから出てくる仕入れてくれるすべての資源で幸福だけ脳細胞が作っちゃうんです
それはもう宗教家のいい加減なデタラメな話じゃないんです
人類見てください 幸福な人はいつでも幸福でしょうに
楽しい人はいつでも楽しい
それは脳の問題なんです
そういうことで我々は瞑想しなさいと言うんです
瞑想というのは決して暗い仕事じゃないんです
暗くて嫌でやるもんじゃないんです
そうやる人々もいますけどね
私はそういう人々は自分おっしゃってる釈尊の仏教徒ではないんだと
自分勝手にレッテルを貼って落ち着いているんです
なぜなら見ていると見ていられないんです
やり方まずくて悪くて
言うんでも言っても言っても聞いてくれない
そうすると後ろ側として腹が立っちゃうんですよ
私はそんな馬鹿なことしないんです
私はもう何があっても心の中で何でもふざけて遊んでるんです
ですから じゃあこの人は仏教の形やっている邪教だと
だからいいんじゃないですか
その人のやり方あるとはね
もう一緒に瞑想しているんだけど
たまにそういう風に自分自分一人悲しくなっちゃうんで
間違っていることを見て
かえってかわいそうにもなりますけど
でもそれでも慈悲があるんだから
まあちゃんと時と時間
時間ではなくて その人に聞ける状態になったならば
ちゃんと教えますけどね
そこまで待ってるんですね
気長くして 聞くところまで聞いてくれるまで諦めて
ダメでした なんとか教えてくださいと言うと
まあこういうことやと
ですから この瞑想っていうのはすごく明るい仕事なんです
だからそれは本当の瞑想を知ったって人が瞑想したったらぶん殴るそうと言ったって瞑想するんです
瞑想なんかしちゃったらご飯あげませんよと言ったらいいですよと言って
それやる それぐらい幸福を味わえるんです
だからストーリーにあるでしょうに
この殺すぞと言ったってもやったと
それぐらいもう正しい道に入れば
すごいもうまだ簡単しです
から 幸福になる方法っていうのは脳細胞に教えてあげることなんです
幸福になる方法 ウェディングドレス買うんじゃなくて
だからとにかく僕はこの面白おかしくたとえ話言ったんだけど
このたとえ話の中に深い心理があるんです
ですから 分からなくなったら
僕のはあまりにも大げさなたとえ話をまた思い浮かんでください
このすごい真剣に喋ってるんです
ウェディングドレスの話
ずっともう 20 20枚ぐらい買ってくださいというのは
ただの面白い面白い話じゃないんです
そこをすごい真剣に高度な哲学そこにあるんです
いわゆる物からは幸福を得られないということ
物から得られるのは一回きりだと
ということだから ですから
いつでもそう思い出して
幸福になってみてください
幸福になりたければなんですけどね
なりたくなければそのままで結構ですけど
で それから もっと簡単
もう一つ 瞑想の方法ってたくさんあります
たくさんあります で 皆様にこの我々このよく日本で教えていますから
この歩く瞑想がございまして
歩くこと それも今ちょっと幸福になることだけ話します
究極的な仏教で仰ってる超越した出世間的な幸福じゃなくて
世俗的な幸福を得ること
で で みんな歩く時はもうすごく世の中にある全ての荷物を背負って歩くんです
歩けないんです うちそのものを背負っているし
家族そのものを背負っているし
会社も目線も背負っているし
だから歩くって疲れるでしょ
疲れるどころか不思議なんですよ
うちを全部背負って 家族も背負って
会社そのものを背負ってよく歩くもんですね
あれ だから歩いたってみんなに面白くないんですね
いつでも何かもう荷物を持って歩くんだから
買い物に至っても 家族のことやら病気のことやら健康のことやら
ありとあらゆる荷物を持って歩くんですね
だから歩くこと楽しめないんですね
どうせ歩くんだから 極度に幸福を感じて楽しんで歩いてみたらいかがでしょうか
歩き方なんですけど もうまずかっこよく歩く
こうやってなんかもう
人からいっぱい借金して
なんかもうみんな大体このこうやってね
背中がこう まだこんな感じで歩くんですね
すっごいもう気持ちも悪いし
格好も悪いし もう誰に怖がってるんですかね
ですから まず背筋を伸ばして
いくら寒くたってもこうしてはいけないんです
まあ寒い時はまあ自然にこうなっちゃうでしょ
寒い時とか まああれはもう動物だからね
犬もね 猫もね やっぱり寒い時はこうやってぐるっと回っちゃう
それはもうこちらのね
機能守らなくちゃいけないんだからね
ですから それはまあ自然になりますけど
その時も寒い時でも 何のことなく怖くないんだと
こうやって歩いてみてください
背筋を伸ばして 寒い ものすごい寒い時でも
散歩歩くとあの寒さ忘れちゃうんです
何のことなく もういくら寒い風が吹いても堂々と歩けるんです
そこで寒い時はもうちょっと暖かくなろうとこうなってみてください
どんどん寒くなるんです
だから歩く時は背筋を伸ばす
まずこうやって背筋を伸ばして
きちんと で 体を動かさないんです
体を動かすということは
もう仕事多いんですね
そうすると 歩くのは大体足で歩くんだからね
私は知ってる限り限りは肩で歩く人も腰で歩く人もいるんだけどね
ですから まあそれで苦しいでしょうね
膝で歩くとかね 肘で歩くとか
逆立ちして歩くとかできるんだけど
まあ余計で苦しいだけですから
歩くということはもう足で歩く
ですから こうやってまっすぐ立って
体の上半身は全く動かさないで
足の動きをちゃんと感じながら
この体のシステムを感じながら
骨組みがあって このこちらで骨がなんか機械みたいにきちんと左
右とちゃんと覚えてるんですよ
それを感じながら 脳にインプットしながら
この体を 歩いてみてください
大体四畳半ぐらい歩くと
なんか自分が空気の上にずっと浮いてるんじゃないかなと感じ始めます
体重が消えちゃうんです
ですから その時はこの脳にインプットするんです
この体の感覚を ですから
この余計なことを考えちゃうと
もう家の荷物 家族 会社背負って歩いちゃったらダメだから
軽くならない ですから
それは荷物置いておく
今は歩くことだけですと
ですから 頭の中で左足
右足 左足 右足 左足 右足
いくらかの落ちついてるペースで左足
右足 左足 右足 すごく美しい
もう早く歩いたっても
早く歩いたっても こういう風に早く歩いたっても
このリズムを壊さない
歩くリズム この美しい姿を
速く歩けば結構早く歩けるんだけどね
で 私は大体この女性の方っていうのはあんまり落ち着きがないんだから
歩く時早いこと 早いんだけど
動かないの そのものすごくなんかカタツムリみたい
なぜかというと 頭の中で悩みやら問題やら苦しみやらいっぱいでしょうに
体はこうやって動くんです
腰は動くわ 足が動くわ
手が動くわ 肩見ると肩こうこう動いてないんです
進んでないんです 今日も同じ経験なんですけど
新宿から出てこちらまで来ると
みんな忙しいこと でもみんなそっちの方向
僕はこっちなんです すーっとこっち側出てたんだから
何のことは でも前並んで歩くと邪魔だからね
だから歩く時でも並んで横に並んで歩いてほしくないんだけど
でもみんな私より 20倍疲れると思いますよ
なぜならば 肩を動かすために
お腹を動かすために 腰の方を動かすために
それで足を動かすために
その上すごいもう 40 センチぐらい長いかかとの靴
[笑い]面白くないんですかね
あれでもこうやって指で立ってるでしょうに
だからどうせ男性よりはね
バランスが良くない それで
体に悪いんですよ 女性っていうのはもっとね
腰の方から大事にしなくちゃいけないんだから
男の人よりは腰の方に仕事多いんだから
だから自分の大事な体なのに
まあそれはどうでもいいんだけど
まあかかと長いものを履いていればどうせこうやって歩いていく
それはその時でも美しく歩けるんです
その時でも 足だけを動かして
左足 右足 左足 右足 左足
右足 そのリズムを感じて
頭にそれだけこの感覚だけインプットするんです
インプットすると 大体ほんの 20 分歩くと
なんとなく綺麗に自分の体が動く
動く 動いていることがわかるようになるんですね
そうすると もうちょっとやっちゃうと
なんか空気の上に動いてるよ
なんかシャボン玉みたいに何かサーッと動いてるんじゃないか
体重がどんどんどんどんわからなくなっちゃうんです
それで驚いちゃったらダメなんですけど
驚かないで それは覚えておくんです
あまり驚いてはいけませんよ
幸福を感じたのに 幸福を感じて驚く人は
不幸を感じたったらドーンとどん底に落ちてるんだからね
だからその真ん中にいることが大事なんですね
これ私が言った通りにあっても驚く必要ないんです
私に電話して 本当にびっくりしました
先生おっしゃった通りで
電話かけてこないでください
僕はびっくりしませんだから
僕の反応 ああそう それだけ
それでみんながっかりするんです
せっかく自分の結果言ったのに
なんでこの人の反応はと
僕はもうああそう それだけ
ああ素晴らしいですって絶対言わない
そういうくだらない世界はもうとっくに昔に終わったんです
ですから もし間違ったとかね
勉強したい もっとやり方どうかなと
そういう教えてほしいところはいつでもどうぞ
素晴らしかったとか 言ったら私のちょっと損します
たまに電話かけてくる人々は
この私もみんなと同じだとすごい勘違いして
まず褒めるんですね 本当に素晴らしかったとか
もう私はもう本当に幸せですと
先生の話を聞かれると
こちらでもうくだらない話ばっかり
いつこの電話切ろうかなって気持ちばっかりなの
その時は せっかく自分の楽しみ消えてるんだと
むしろそうじゃなくて
実は私はこういうこういうことをやってましたけど
ここら辺がちょっとわからないんだけど
どうですか？と言った途端
私はすごく喜びを感じるんです
あ 私の仕事だと それを私は教えてあげなくちゃいけないんだ
そこでものすごく丁寧に
わかりやすく きちんとその人の性格に合うように言うんです
それで私を褒めてあげて
踊らせてあげて あげて
教えてもらおうと思ったら
私にすぐバレますからね
大体電話を取るともう心読んでいるんです
だからまあ損するだけ
ですから そういう余計な話で時間なくなったんだけどね
一応驚いてはいけないという
ただそれだけのことなんです
もし空気の上に動いているように感じても
驚いてはいけないんです
ただ ものすごく大人になって
心落ち着いたらそんなもんだと
やっぱり心落ち着いたらね
歩くことも苦しいんじゃないんだ
これも楽しいもんだ 結構と
そういう風に大人の感覚で理解してください
やっぱり心落ち着いて歩くというのは結構楽しいもんですね
結構歩けるもんですねとかね
今まで歩くのは苦痛でしたけどね
なかなか歩けるんじゃないかなと
それで 1 日 1時間とか 2時間とか歩いてみてください
もう体は本当はカロリーを燃やしてるし
でも全然疲れてない で
健康的になるんじゃないんですか
自分の何て言いますか
歩行者になるあだ子だとかね
スマートになるとか なんだかんだ何のことなく出てきます
そこでこの体の動きからの脳がこの既視感を感じることができるんです
そういう正しいことから覚えてほしい
音楽聴いて楽しもうと思ったらもうひどい目に遭うし
美味しいご飯を食べて楽しもうと思ったら
それはまた後で結果が待ってますから
落とし穴があるんだから
そう ここで落とし穴ないでしょ
それからもう一つ なんか疲れてくるともう一つ方法があります
例えばこの これは瞑想を途中でやれるもんですけど
ちょっと難しいんだけど
で あまりうまくいかないかもしれません
だけど 瞑想いくらかもう進んでいる人々には
この法則のね この猛烈な速さでこの動いていることと
この時間の速さというのを感じさせるために
このちょっとやります
それで そこからちょっとしたこの一般的な解釈なんですけど
で あの ちょっとあの手を上げてみる方法があります
で その時もまあ座ってでもいいんだけど
まあ例えばあの こんなこういうぐらいに手を置いておいて
あまりにもこの難しい
この格好つけたらでもダメなんです
ですから この座って机の上でも机の上でもなんか軽く手を置いて
それから目を閉じる 目を閉じて究極的なスローモーション
頭でこの 1コマ 1コマごとにコマ単位で手を動か上へ上へ上がってみるんです
ですから この究極的なスローモーションだから
見ている人には見えないかも
手の動き それくらいゆっくりと手を上へ上へ上がっての上げてみるんです
そこであの基本言いますけど
例えば 15 センチぐらい手を上げるならば
できれば 15 分かけて上げてみてください
難しくないでしょ？別に
ただ 十五センチぐらい
これからこれぐらいの手を上げる
例えばへそのところから胸のところまで手を上げる
それにちょっと十五分ぐらいかけてみる
でもずっと集中して落ち着いて
頭の中手をいっぱい感じて
手の動きを明確に こむごとにゆっくりゆっくりゆっくり動かしてみる
その時何も感じないで
頭の中で上げます 上げますでもいいんですね
感じること 手で感じることを言ってもいいし
上げます 上げます でもいいんだけど
ちょっとやってみて 上げてみてください
最初難しいかもしれませんから
この五分ぐらいかけて
ちょっとスローモーションで手を上げてみる
それから同じくスローモーションで手を下げてみる
そのきめ細かいこの動きを脳が体験しちゃうと
恐ろしい素晴らしい経験が出てくる
ものすごく心はリラックスするんです
それで覚えちゃったら
いつでも体の動きではないかとわかるんだから
いつでも歩く時でも何かやるとこの楽しみながら
脳にこの喜悦感を味わえながら
ああ嫌ですよとか思って
歯を噛んでペンを取ってものを書くんじゃなくて
その時でも美しくペンを取る感覚
書く感覚 文字が現れる感覚
全部感じながら 何でも楽しくやることはできるんです
それにはまずこのプログラムで脳に方法を教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 大体これぐらいでも結構ですけど
十五分ぐらいかけて手を上げてみること
それから歩いてみると
それで生きてる間では本当の幸福
本当の喜悦感 落ち着き感じるんです
そうすると苛立ち消えちゃうんです
で 抵抗が ほんの何ヶ月間続ければ
もう脳はもう分からなくなっちゃうんですよ
苦しむことやら 怒ることやら
嫉妬することやら くだらなくなっちゃう
分からなくなっちゃうし
くだらなくなっちゃうんです
で そこはまあそこレベルの方法で
同じ方法を進むのなら
仏教で言えばお釈迦様のおっしゃっているこの悟りの境地で超越した境地でもある
最終的にも我々探しているこの欠けているもの見つかる
見つかったらもう探すことは全てそこで消えちゃうんです
ですから 仏佛教では悟ったらもう修行は終了
やることは全部終了 それ以上やることは何もないんです
ただ体があるんだからご飯食べるんだけど
別に目的があるわけじゃない
ただこの機械があるんだからだけのことで
それぐらいになります
それは初期仏教の釈迦の悟り
そういう悟りであって
いろいろ部派仏教の修行下の悟りはまた違うかもしれませんけど
それはもう宗教の世界だから
いろいろ解釈あるのかもしれませんだけど
釈迦さんはそういう風に
見つかったならば また探す必要ないんだと
修行には終わりがないとかなんとか仏教では言わない
お釈迦様が言わない 終わりがあると
座禅には目的はないと
目的がある ないではなくて
で 道元禅師の教えをいろいろ解釈する方々は
悟りはないんだと 悟りと修行は同じだとか大嘘を言ってるんだけど
あるんですから 初期仏教だったら
自分にないんだから人にない
冗談じゃないんだけど
で まあそれはその人たちがそう言いたければそれは世間の理由ですけど
一応あるんですね 生命に我々が何か欠けてるっていうことはあるんだから
その欠けているもの見つかれば
もうそれから探し求めるのが終わるんです
それは仏教の最終的な悟りなんですね
そこまで苦しんでくださいではなくて
今からこの方法で味わってみてください
幸福感 それは無常だから成り立つんです
無常でなきゃ成り立たない
何も変わりませんだから
無常でなきゃ 無常だからやれば変わるんです
で 話はもう三十分に取りまして
質問の時間なくなっちゃうんですけど
申し訳ないんですけど
どうもありがとうございました
[終始拍手]